Selena Gomez's surprising new admission
quote I knew what it meant to be bullied
it's hard she revealed that in a new
interview with The New York Times while
promoting her new Netflix series
thirteen reasons why centered on a high
school you want to have a turn just
press play
Selena understands the high school
hardships quote I went to the biggest
high school in the world which is the
Disney Channel Disney Channel is
definitely a machine but the 24 year
olds Disney days weren't all bad
she says she was the happiest when she
got to tape Wizards of Waverly Place in
front of a live audience of kids she
blames social media for changing the
game quote I watched it go from zero to
a hundred Selena says she deletes
Instagram once a week to try and avoid
the negative comments quote it's like
they want to cut your soul
imagine all the insecurities that you
already feel about yourself and having
someone write a paragraph pointing out
every little thing on social media it's
as much as its blessing and it's fun it
can really tear people down and I always
hope that the people I'm involved with
or support me can just kind of spread
love within that
[Music]